[Musique]
vous l'avez compris le monde change le
monde change fondamentalement et souvent
vous vous avez un manque de lisibilité
sur l'actualité sur ce qui se passe sur
le monde sur les hors-jeu et notamment
sur la nouvelle donne géopolitique
mondiale alors mon propos de ce soir va
être de vous essayez de vous amener à
vous poser les bonnes questions à mettre
les mots les références sur finalement
si qui occupe mon esprit ce qui occupe
vraiment l'actualité et finalement sans
une grande traduction ni objectifs
finalement bien défini le monde change
mais il est confus le monde change mais
il a besoin de clairvoyance
donc je vais tâcher ici de vous ramener
un petit peu à cette actualité
ce que vous dire également c'est que
l'actualité aujourd'hui manque de relief
tout est sur le même plan il n'ya plus
de distinction entre la météo de demain
et finalement le changement climatique
avec le petit événement quotidien et
finalement les choses fondamentales la
semaine dernière l'état d'israël a
frappé en syrie
des chiites
les mots vous les connaissez vous avez
entendu par les aciéries
l'état d'israël bien évidemment ai
entendu parler des chiites
mais quelle lisibilité finalement vous
avez de la chose et finalement quels
sont les enjeux qui sont liées à cette
intervention israélienne
c'est bien plus grave que de petites
affaires dont on vous parle tous au
quotidien dans les journaux
d'information continue donc c'est un
piège dans lequel il faut pas tomber et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on va
tâcher ensemble d'éclairer un petit peu
cette actualité alors rapidement voir un
passeur un policier ensemble bien sûr
d'organiser votre pensée regardez cette
carte
bon c'est à deux heures d'avion de
chinois
certains pays à une heure et demie mais
rapidement cette carte du proche et
moyen orient et de l'afrique arabe
rapidement déjà il faut distinguer bien
évidemment l'afrique arabe de l'afrique
noire
c'est pareil par le sahara donc je vais
vous parler de l'afrique arabe mais
surtout pour bien comprendre cette
région et qui va expliquer ce qui passe
aujourd'hui il faut que vous intégriez
une distinction fondamentale la première
distinction fondamentale c'est que vous
voyez là où l'iran c'est la frontière
entre deux mondes
cette frontière séculaire qui va
aujourd'hui organiser toutes les
tensions dans la région si la frontière
entre le monde arabe et le monde perse
les iraniens ne sont pas arabes ils sont
perse et c'est ainsi que vous avez des
tensions entre ces deux peuples tension
séculaire attention ces tensions sont
telles qu'elles vont au delà de
l'inimitié avec le monde occidental
voire même de l'inimitié avec l'état
d'israël
ce sont des tensions terribles la peur
bleue aujourd'hui de l'arabie saoudite
c'est si l'iran à l'armé nucléaire dans
la semaine il leur faudra l arme
nucléaire
donc voyez l'enjeu car notamment quand
donald trump est en train aujourd'hui
d'intervenir sur la question iranienne
autre chose qu'il faut que vous
compreniez dans cette zone c'est que les
arabes aujourd'hui ne représente qu'un
sixième des musulmans de la planète
5/6 des musulmans ne sont pas arabes
dans cette région ils sont perse l'iran
ils sont turcs
ils sont afghans ils sont surtout
asiatiques un milliard de musulmans sur
la planète ne sont pas arabes
d'ailleurs tous les arabes ne sont pas
musulmans
beaucoup d'arbres sont chrétiens
vous avez souvent entendu parler des
minorités chrétiennes dans ces
régions-là notamment rencontré parlera
et que donc forcément tout ça amène à
des réflexions mais aujourd'hui on va
s'attarder sur cette première inimitiés
donc il faut maîtriser absolument les
choses pour comprendre ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et demain la première 6
limitiez je voulais dit c'est cette
frontière entre le monde arabe et le
monde perse
lors de la seconde guerre en irak goyer
l'irak
qui reprendre le bastion arabe
d'opposition à la perse d'où la guerre
iran irak de 1980 à 1988 après la
révolution iranienne islamistes les
panarabistes laïque se sont donc opposés
à l'iran à l'époque de communic huit ans
de guerre terrible qui oppose et encore
une fois les arabes et perses
sauf que la deuxième guerre en irak sein
est celle où les français s'étaient
opposés notamment par la voix de jacques
chirac et de dominique de villepin à
l'onu les 10 ans il faut pas y aller
c'est une faute historique
les américains ont débarqué en irak ont
déstabilisé le monde arabe est
aujourd'hui les forces perses pénètre
en irak et ont pénétré en syrie il se
trouve que cette inimitié a comme
conséquence aussi historique que les
perses pratiquer une religion musulmane
différente de celle de leur opposant
musulmans arabes sunnites les perses son
shit
les perses et en chine cette opposition
au sunnisme font que les minorités
chiites commencent à rentrer donc en
irak en syrie et au sud liban avec le
hezbollah chiite
ainsi aujourd'hui vous avez cette
opposition et vous voyez donc que le
monde arabe se fait encercler par le
nord par l'irak est la sienne et bien le
monde arabe aussi à une problématique au
yémen c'est la guerre actuelle que vous
suivez puisque vous avez les chiites
financé par l'iran qui combattent
aujourd'hui en opposition les arabes de
l'arabie saoudite au yémen c'est une
guerre un petit peu comme quand nous
avions cette opposition entre les états
unis et la russie lé fait l'urss d'antan
ou au soudan les guerres par
l'intermédiaire d'autres nations
d'autres pays plus loin donc au yémen ne
vous trompez pas c'est encore une fois
la guerre entre les percées les arabes
ils sont aujourd'hui donc entouré comme
une mâchoire par la pression chiite au
sud et au nord et cadence donald trump
je me retire
vous retirer
si donald trump se retire qui va être le
garant de la sécurité
de l'état israël a pris ses
responsabilités l'état israël qui a une
peur bleue des islamistes iranienne est
allé frapper en syrie les chiites
cette opposition naturellement elle est
permanente et si vous devez avoir une
lisibilité dans l'actualité quelque
chose qui va vous confortez intégré au
moins ce premier ce premier élément
l'opposition entre les perses chiite et
le monde arabe pour l'essentiel sunnite
hormis les arabes chrétiens dont on
parlera si vous voulez tout à l'heure
pendant le débat allez je vais vous
rassurer vous montrer quelque chose un
peu plus comme au nab à las et la carte
avec laquelle vous avez vécu avec
laquelle vous avez grandi
celle qui fait qu'ils aient vraiment
confortement installé dans vos agendas
on sait jamais si vous l'avez oublié et
l'a rapidement qu est ce que vous voyez
notre avenir rassurez vous les français
quittent à découper le monde aux soins
au centre sommes français et que donc
forcément la lisibilité immédiate
appareils nous sommes donc aujourd'hui
tranquillement en train de regarder
notre avenir notre avenir il est clair
c'est l'atlantique nord ce sont les
états unis enfin le continent américain
c'est une carte tout à fait logique pour
nous l'avenir du monde pour nous c'est
de notre bassin méditerranéen et puis
l'europe
et puis bien sûr l'atlantique nord là
aussi une distinction l'atlantique nord
l'atlantique sud ne nous concerne pas
donc l'atlantique nord et donc vous avez
retrouvé la carte et nos alliances
traditionnelles notamment noah alliance
militaire
le fameux l'otan organisation du traité
de l'atlantique nord
et pour nous c'est une logique et nous
vivons avec ça et nous parlons d'europe
etc
et ça c'est notre monde c'est votre
culture la culture sens géopolitique du
terme c'est à dire la culture telle qu
on est né on nous a donné des choses des
éléments et nous vivons avec ça
sauf que le monde il est pas pareil
partout j'ai pris le globe j'ai fait ça
hop et là vous imaginer quoi que les
américains ont déjà un choix que nous
n'avons pas
les américains ont un choix entre
l'atlantique nord et le pacifique
les américains ont deux visions du monde
l'atlantique nord qui était intéressant
mais aujourd'hui la chine se réveille
aujourd'hui l'asie la zone pacifique à
un enjeu fondamental la californie côte
ouest tout seul séparément une seule et
américains s'il était indépendant
aujourd'hui reprend très la 6e forces
économiques de la planète à qui m
économie la planète donc la côte
pacifique américaine est fondamentale
aujourd'hui les américains regardez la
carte souvent je ne comprends pas des
politiques de européens qui viennent
s'aligner sur une pensée politique
américaine
regardez au niveau de la défense ils
sont protégés par deux océans
c'est plus qu'une île de l'océan qui
voulez vous qu'ils viennent intervenir à
ce que les américains jours auront
verront débarquer sur la cote comme nous
on a vu où c'est fermé hier x fois une
population jamais de la vie
quel est le risque américaine de prendre
aux missiles ils ont créé le bouclier
antimissile et éventuellement d'avoir
quelqu'un qui pénètre l'état américain
pour y faire vous pouvez commettre un
attentat donc le contrôle aux frontières
qui est exacerbé aux états unis mais
c'est tout à fait logique
on est dans la politique américaine sauf
qu'on ne peut absolument pas pratiqué en
europe donc déjà vous comprenez en
regardant la carte beaucoup de choses
c'est que les américains commencent à
s'intéresser de plus en plus sa zone
pacifique est de moins en moins la nôtre
c'est pour ça qu obama a commencé à se
retirer du proche et moyen-orient de
l'aciérie et qu'à laisser place à
l'arrivée de poutine
ou soutien de bachar al assad poutine
soutiennent désir a nié gîte
ça va vous voyez là quartier l'arabie
saoudite israël avec des états unis vous
avez la nouvelle carte du monde qui se
dessine et que donc les américains sont
là en train de vous poser des questions
sincère sur l'avenir du monde et
l'avenir du monde pour eux il est plutôt
aujourd'hui orientée vers l'océan
pacifique
il n'y a plus de doute c'est la vision
du monde vue de la chine
cette carte est étonnante
voire de l'europe
on n'est plus du tout sur la carte fait
on est sur notre problème c'est notre
première carte
il y avait là la scala ou pas je suppose
que tous les matins morazan open çà
l'alaska maintenant
une autre chose à faire notamment la
chine n'oubliez pas aussi que
l'essentiel de la population chinoise
vit sur lorient c'est à dire sur la mer
de chine
les hauts plateaux tibétaine très peu
habitées et que donc l'essentiel du
monde pacifique s'organise la nouvelle
donne géopolitique apparaît elle est
claire elle est nette
elle apparaît dans l'océan pacifique les
pays de l'asie du sud-est se sont
également organisées ils ont créé comme
union européenne ça s'appelle l'asian
l'association des nations du sud-est
asiatique dont vous avez la thaïlande
etc
vous avez la chine tiens vous avez le
japon la corée du nord et vous avez la
russie tient nous nous pensions avec la
première carte que si les américains
vous devez avoir affaire aux russes ils
devaient nous passer sur le corps pas du
tout et ça me fasse en hausse et le
détroit de béring entre l'alaska et la
russie en dessous juste au dessus de la
chine à 110 km de la corée du nord
vous avez vladivostok le port de
commerce le plus important et militaires
de russes vous avez le japon rêver
l'australie et la nouvelle-zélande
vous avez les etats-unis le canada le
mexique avec sa côte pacifique
acapulco et puis vous avez le chili et
vous dites et nous on est où là
les européens
on se pose encore des questions si la
pertinence européenne existe imaginez en
plus que ces pays de la zone pacifique
s'organisent entre eux
une fois drôle l'organisation existe
c'est l'asian pacific economic
cooperation
ils travaillent ensemble tout le temps
au centre de l'île pacifique vous avez
hawaï et là où est né barack obama
aujourd'hui travaillent tous ensemble
ils ont monté une communauté économique
alors elle est moins contraignante que
l'union européenne mais les hyper
dynamique
je peux vous rassurer quand je suis allé
au vietnam les premiers titres de
l'actualité c'était l'apec l'apec l'apex
et leur avenir c'est leur développement
c'est la zone pacifique
donc en voyant toutes ces questions
j'espère que vous allez avoir un peu
plus de lisibilité
vous avez compris doucement les enjeux
et ce qui se passe dans l'actualité donc
trump ne veut plus financer l'otan vous
l'avez entendu ça l'organisation du
traité atlantique nord
ils veulent mettre et concentrer leurs
forces sur la zone pacifique sur leur
nouvelle opposition avec la chine et sur
les nouveaux enjeux qui vont représenter
quasiment la totalité du commerce
mondial
et que nous nous devons réinventer
d'autres enjeux parce qu'il faut les
mesurer
nous sommes là dans la nouvelle donne
géopolitique mondiale et que donc si ça
s'est mal maîtrisé nous allons passer à
côté de notre histoire
l'europe a des atouts la france a des
atouts vous le savez deux de ces pays
sont membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu deux de ces pays en
larmes nucléaire et vous savez que dans
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
l'om sait qu'elle est la première
puissance commerçante du monde un peu
économique est commerçant du monde
c'est l'europe
aujourd'hui quand l'europe s'assoie à la
table des négociations les plus
puissantes que les états unis la chine
on écoute
à condition de savoir avancer ses pions
parce qu'on n'a pas le choix
alors que ça nous plaise ou non cette
donne elle existe elle est là
et donc cela nous ramène à des questions
les questions de lisibilité politique de
à voir vous avez compris que transfert
de la puissance géopolitique mondiale
est passée de l'océan atlantique nord
vers l'océan pacifique
vous avez compris que les enjeux nous
échappent aujourd'hui mais que le monde
avance et qu'on n'a pas le choix il faut
pas faire comme si ça ne bougeait pas si
on décide de freiner de se réorganiser
le reste force
donc on a une responsabilité tous
ensemble
la fin du tout prouvé ou la peur du
déclassement
ça c'est une question importante c'est
une mutation sociologique avant le
progrès
petit quelque chose de fondamental on
invente la machine à laver
j'étais persuadé que ma fille allait
avoir plus de confort qui moi l'erreur
au lavoir le prouve et garantissez amal
nouvelle génération à mes enfants de
vivre mieux que moi aujourd'hui le tout
pourrait cette mondialisation ne nous
garantit pas forcément un avenir serein
du coup on a peur du déclassement du
coup on va vers le repli sur soi mais le
monde avance
est ce que c'est la solution voilà les
vraies questions c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui cette question de
déclassement est au centre de notre
actualitté sociologique française en
marque de ça il ya aussi quelque chose
qui va nous déstabiliser c'est le
rapport la vérité l'information est-elle
multiples et lisible que le rapport à la
vérité change
vous avez aujourd'hui des hommes
politiques est ouvertement monte à la
télévision
mais c'est plus grave puisque
aujourd'hui elle n'a plus d'intérêt
politique et sociale mais c'est très
embêtant pour une démocratie
nous sommes une organisation
démocratique et que le rapport à la
vérité était le fondement et le soc
notre civilisation et que donc
aujourd'hui cette question doit revenir
au centre des débats
vous allez bientôt avoir une loi sur les
fesses news qui empoisonne aujourd'hui
l'actualité les élections dans les pays
démocratiques comme on a vu aux états
unis est-ce que trump avec la russie etc
et puis la crise de la démocratie
libérale
c'est ce que vous connaissez aujourd'hui
d'où les questionnements et peut-être
pour ça que vous êtes venus ici et donc
en conséquence ce manque de lisibilité
et ce manque de clarté mais j'espère une
chose sauf si vous allez avoir un peu
plus de visibilité et un peu plus de
clarté par sur patins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]